In both Egyptian and Greek mythology, it's said that art was invented by
someone tracing the shadow of a person on a cave wall. Shadows give a scene
more realism and solidity. An object's shadow firmly establishes its location
in relation to its surroundings. Rasterization is focused on triangles rendered
from the eye, so we have to work a bit to generate shadows. One popular method
of adding these is called shadow mapping. This algorithm dates way back. It was
first described by Lance Williams in 1978. The idea is to render the scene from
the point of view of the light. Whatever the light sees, is what gets lit.
Remember our firefly with human eyeballs? This is where that answer comes into
play. If a light doesn't see a surface, that means the surface is in shadow. In
fact, this is exactly how the basic algorithm is done. The scene is rendered
from the view of the light. And the distance of the closest objects is stored
at each pixel. Because the light has to look in a particular direction, and has
a limited field of view the light source used for shadow mapping is often a
spotlight of some sort. A spotlight can be pointed in a direction, and has a
constrained view of the world. In 3JS the only lights capable of casting
shadows are spotlights and directional lights. For directional lights, you
specify the limits of how wide the light extends.